[Crissement de pneus
et portière qui se referme.]
-Barbès.
-Bienvenue chez Joe.
...
-Joe le taxi,
il va pas partout,
il marche pas au soda.
Son saxo jaune
connaît toutes les rues par coeur.
Tous les petits bars,
tous les coins noirs.
Et la Seine
et ses ponts qui brillent.
Dans sa caisse,
la musique à Joe,
c'est la rumba.
Le vieux rock au mambo.
Joe le taxi,
c'est sa vie, le rhum au mambo,
embouteillage.
Il est comme ça,
rhum et mambo,
Joe,
Joe, Joe.
Dans sa caisse,
la musique à Joe résonne.
C'est la rumba,
le vieux rock au mambo bidon.
Vas-y Joe.
Vas-y, fonce
dans la nuit, vers l'Amazone.
Joe le taxi
et Xavier Cugat.
et Yma Sumac.
...
Joe le taxi, c'est sa vie,
le rhum au mambo,
embouteillage.
Joe le taxi
et les mariachis.
et le cha-cha-chi.
Joe le taxi
Vas-y Joe.
Vas-y, fonce.